for the British MEP s who wanted to
remain in the European Union and their
European colleagues it was an emotional
moment as the EU Parliament ratified the
withdrawal agreement paving the way for
Britain to leave the EU on Friday
earlier in a debate some European
leaders expressed regret over budget and
said it was the end of an era
I want to use the words of the famous
British poet George Eliot she said only
in the agony of parting do we look into
the depths of love we will always love
you and we will never be far long live
Europe and I think that I can say in the
name of all of us on all groups
I can only say we will miss you in the
coming time and in the community the
warm goodbyes nostalgia was cut thought
by brexit party leader Nigel Farage in
the future if you disobey the rules you
get cut off put your flags away you're
leaving and take them with you
James walls who quit his job as a civil
servant to campaign for brexit it was a
moment to relish we believed in
democracy and sovereignty so it's
nothing to do with European peoples and
their and in the European countries this
is all about the European Union the
institution these are some of the
British MPs who are now packing up and
preparing to leave Brussels of course
for those who supported and wanted
fridged it is a moment of celebration
but for those who wanted to remain part
of the European Union or some say
they're devastated British Green Party
MEP Alexandre Philips spent the morning
clearing her office I think the next 11
months we need to focus on ensuring that
the UK is properly aligned as closely as
possible to the EU and that we don't end
up and a race to the bottom on all sorts
of standards
protections including workers rights and
environmental protections Britain has
been part of the EU for nearly half a
century ending a long relationship is
never easy equally challenging is
working out how to get on when forced to
cooperate with months of negotiations
ahead over a future relationship those
here know that the hard part is just
beginning
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Brussels